la unión europea insiste en que hay que
seguir ayudando a ucrania por ello el
jefe de la diplomacia europea
josep borrell que viajó precisamente a
la ciudad de kiev la semana pasada ha
anunciado que los países de la unión
europea proveerán con ayuda financiera a
la fiscalía ucraniana la fiscalía de la
corte penal internacional y también se
desplegará por parte de la uv de la
unión europea una misión especial para
poder documentar posibles crímenes de
guerra perpetrados por parte de las
tropas rusas en ucrania si se ha
decidido en una reunión de cancilleres
europeos en que también se han reunido
con el fiscal jefe de la corte penal
internacional que ha decidido abrir una
investigación sobre los sucesos en
ucrania josep borrell ha alertado que el
obispo no crea ni han sido asesinatos
masivos bombardeos y tal y como ha
advertido ucrania se teme algo peor en
la región del donbass en el este del
país con un mayor despliegue de tropas
rusas por ello la unión europea tiene
previsto enviar 500 millones de euros
más para financiar armas para ucrania lo
que suma un total de 1500 millones de
euros